some things really are classics they
never go out of style like jean jackets
or aviators and prints and blackberries
this is the blackberry classic and it's
a throwback to everything that made a
blackberry well a blackberry it's got a
fantastic physical keyboard that always
reliable led to tell you you've got a
message and a trackpad
it even has brickbreaker right as I was
saying using the blackberry classic
which goes for four hundred and fifty
dollars unlocked on Amazon there's a lot
like going back to 2004 when we used our
smart phones mostly for work and email
that's a great thing if you can get more
done with a physical keyboard but very
frustrating if you want to do more if
you are a blackberry user or were a
blackberry user reuniting what the
classic feels like reuniting with the
best friend
unlike BlackBerry's passport the classic
is perfect for one hand use the aluminum
sides and soft plastic back make the
phone feel weighty but really
substantial and then there's your
glorious almost perfect keyboard your
rows separated by metal frets as
perfectly sculpted keys so I can type
without having to look down instead of
the row of navigation buttons and the
trackpad blackberry could have made the
three-and-a-half inch touchscreen bigger
but I have to say I missed this little
thing it's great for editing an email
with more precision also brickbreaker
but there's a lot of new stuff here too
the BlackBerry 10 web browser is now
really really fast and it's easy to get
to all your messages plus the BlackBerry
email and calendar apps still beat iOS
and Android for me the battery isn't
removable but I've been getting a full
day's charge and this thing works great
as an actual phone but why I look for
some of those blackberry features to
make a comeback others just feel so
stuck in the past well you can download
Android apps from Amazon store many big
ones are missing including a really good
Maps app a pre-loaded one is useful if
you need to know if you're in Midtown
and yes you can load other Android apps
manually on the phone like Instagram but
it takes some work and even then when it
comes to taking pictures the classic
can't keep up with Android or iPhones
I also found the classic to be slow at
times taking too much time to open an
app or webpage the classic lives up to
its name in fact this is the best
blackberry ever and the phone to get if
you need a real physical keyboard to
plow through emails manage your calendar
and search the web and pretty much
nothing else when you're using it you
feel like no time has passed at all and
that of course is its biggest drawback